[Musique]
ce
week end dans le pré c'est l'amour de la
mécanique 40 kilomètres heure la vitesse
n'est pas des plus impressionnantes sauf
quand l'engin pèse trois tonnes
[Musique]
fête à l'école j'en aurai plus en plus
pour communiquer positivement sur notre
métier savoir expliquer aux gens ce que
l'on fait comme mon travail etc mais moi
ce bateau c'est pour le folklore sermet
envie d vieille batteuse qui sont
entrain de dps qui partiront à la
ferraille soit qu'ils vont rester dans
la cour de ferme où ça permet de les
remettre vie et de profiter de ces bons
moments pour pour faire une cohésion
entre tous nos adhérents d'un côté la
fête de l'autre la piste et premier tour
pour marine au volant de sa bête le
pilotage demande un peu de prise en main
première force de toute ma vie
vos impressions
c'est assez compliqué ça fait mal aux
bras et non c'est cool
question puissance avec son moteur de
machines à betteraves la moissonneuse de
florent guilloteau surclasse ses
concurrents le grand favori vient du
nord du département
on était une équipe de jeunes ya une
dizaine d'années quand on a voulu
relancer le mode bat cross dans
l'oreille on a essayé de faire une
machine de en état pour pour avancer
vite quoi les roues à l'arrière en fait
quand on tournait revoir l'arrière de la
machine balle aille beaucoup plus et
donc quand on a une machine à côté en
train de doubler espère doubler du coup
faut faire attention où sinon
c'est divertissant
c'est bien pour
cette apc c'est trop tôt c'est sympa moi
c'est la première année que je le vois
c'est vraiment sympa ya pas mal de choc
pas mal d'action
[Musique]
avec son mois de bahts cross à
marseillan ville est terre en fait s'il
ya un retour en force
[Musique]